the bloodletting in bucha has made it
one of the most notorious examples of
russia's brutality in this war
bodies of murdered ukrainians may no
longer lay in the street and people are
trying to go back to the way things were
but you don't have to go far to see what
the conflict has left behind
sites like these are common in places
that have been taken back from the
russians this tank behind me seems to be
pointing its gun at what might have been
the last thing it was able to shoot at
before it was disabled well completely
destroyed over here is the entrance to
ukrainian army base in the forest now
the russians are no longer there but the
russian threat remains over here is a
sign that says mines which indicates
that beyond this fence there are still
land mines and unexploded ordinance that
has yet to be cleared
masha lived under russian occupation in
a village outside bucha
she lost her uncle brother and best
friend
all three men killed in the same place
at the same time
in the defense of their city
we hoped that it wasn't them until the
dna examination
also many things indicated that it was
true
pain despair emptiness
these are wounds
wounds that will never heal
they were shot
their bodies burned
in what is left of the car where they
died
it smells like death she says
these men were killed more than a month
ago but they were found identified and
buried just days ago
everyone's trumpeting about butcher
everyone's trumpeting about hostimal
about european mario paul the same thing
is happening there in carson it's a
horror it's an absolute horror
as long as there is this evil there will
be war she says
and everyone wants peace
the war in ukraine has broken so many
communities
in the towns and villages around
ukraine's capital
weeks after the slaughter
investigations carry on
and as bodies are identified the list of
bucha's confirmed dead gets longer
there are still more people to bury more
people to mourn
more people to miss
ravi al-jazeera in kozinski village near
buchar